let's see if we can simplify this
expression right over here and write it
in scientific notation so the first
thing I want to do well I already have
parts of this expression that are
written in scientific notation for my
brain to simplify the multiplication I
like to write everything into scientific
notation and then do whatever I need to
do to get it into a final product into
scientific notation so this part right
over here is 0.2 is not in scientific
notation in order for it to be
scientific notation it would we have to
be some number between 1 and 10 not
including 10 so greater than or equal to
1 less than less than 10 being
multiplied by some power of 10 and this
is clearly less than 1 but we could just
view this as look this is this is in the
tenths place this is 2 times 1/10 1/10
is 10 to the negative 1 so this is the
same thing as 2 2 times 10 to the
negative 1 same thing as 2 times 1/10
now if we look in the denominator in
blue we have this part it is written in
scientific notation but this green part
is not but we could easily write it as
this is 5/10 thousands ten thousand is
five is ten to the fourth so this is the
same thing as five times ten to the
fourth power you see that it has one two
three four zeros so now let's take the
product in the numerator in the
denominator so the numerator I'm just
going to swap the order in which I'm
multiplying I'm just multiplying a bunch
of stuff 4.6 times 10 to the sixth times
2 times 10 to the negative 1 it doesn't
matter what order I multiply them in so
I could rewrite this as 4.6 times 2
times 2 times 10 to the sixth switching
colors times 10 to the sixth times 10 to
the negative 1 times 10 to the negative
1 and then in the denominator I've got
five times well let me just write the
five times two point three times two
point three times 10 to the fourth times
10 to the fourth times 10 to the
negative 2 times 10 to the negative 2
and now let us attempt to simplify this
thing so here we have 4 point 6
times two let me circle that so 4.6
times two is nine point two so that's
nine point two and then 10 to the sixth
times 10 to the negative one we have the
same base we're taking the product we
can add the exponents is going to be 10
to the 6 minus 1 or 10 to the fifth
power so times 10 to the fifth power so
we've simplified our numerator and now
in our denominator in our denominator
let's see five times two point three
five times two is 10 5 times 0.3 is 1.5
so it's going to be 11 point five so
this is going to be 11 point five and
then if I multiply 10 to the fourth
times 10 to the negative 2 that's going
to be 10 to the 4 minus 2 or 10 squared
times 10 to the second power and now I
can divide these two things so this is
going to be equal to I'll have to think
about what nine point two over eleven
point five is but actually let me just
do that right now get a little practice
dividing decimals so nine point two give
some real estate here so nine point two
we do that same color nine point two
divided by eleven point five divided by
eleven point five well if we multiply
both of these times ten that's the exact
same thing that's the exact same thing
as 92 divided by 115 we're essentially
moved the decimal to the right for both
of them and let me add some zeros here
because I suspect that I'm going to get
a decimal here so let's think what this
is going to be let's think about this
115 doesn't go into nine it doesn't go
to 92 it does go into 920 and I'm going
to eyeball and say that it will go eight
times let's see if that works out so my
decimal here that's zero eight times
eight times five is forty eight times 11
is 88 and then 88 plus 4 is 92 I went in
exactly very good its 920 we have no
remainder so 9.2 divided by eleven point
five
simplified to 0.8 0.8 and then 10 to the
fifth divided by 10 to the second that's
going to be the same thing as we have
the same base and we're dividing so we
can subtract the exponents that's going
to be 10 to the 5 minus 2 or 10 so this
right over here is going to be 10 to the
third power so times 10 to the third
power now are we done well in order to
be done this number right over here
needs to be greater than or equal to 1
and less than 10 it is clearly not
greater than or equal to 1 so how can we
rewrite this as the product of something
that is greater than or equal to 1 and
less than 10 and some power of 10
well this 8 right over here this is in
the tenths place it's 8 tenths 8 times
1/10 we could rewrite it as so this is
going to be the same thing as 8 times 10
to the negative 1 power and then we have
this 10 to the third here so times so
times 10 to the third power we do that
in that other color times 10 to the
third power and now we have the same
base just add the exponents so this is
going to be equal to 8 times 10 to the 3
minus 1 so 8 times 10 squared and we're
done we've simplified our original
expression